Moins t'es vêtu
et plus t'es... à l'aise.
Moi, quand je pars
en vacances en France
et que je dis "ouais, je viens du Nord"
et que je commence à dire
Valenciennes, Denain, tout ça, euh...
limite si on me demande si je couche pas avec ma sœur, quoi. Donc euh...
faut peut-être pas abuser, quoi.
- C'est ça le football, les gars !
- Eh, je travaille pour Brut,
maintenant, les gars !
- Si la police municipale, maintenant,
se déplace à motocross,
c'est qu'y a une raison !
- La "cassosserie" !
- Y a des Algériens,
y a des Marocains, des Français,
mais on est tous ensemble.
Salut, c'est Yagmur et je
vous emmène à Denain.
Denain, c'est une des villes
les plus pauvres de France
et là bas, la moto
et le foot américain, ça fédère
pas mal de jeunes.
Et grâce à ça, j'ai
pu rencontrer Clément.
Il est coach de foot américain.
Et Amine, il a seize ans
et il est fou de bikelife.
- Bah, la bikelife, c'est : t'es une équipe, t'es à plusieurs,
t'as des motos, t'as des quads
et tu fais que du wheeling,
tu vas zoner dans toutes les villes
et c'est ça, la vraie bikelife, en vrai.
Grâce à la moto,
je connais plein de monde, maintenant.
Moi, j'ai commencé la moto,
j'avais 9 ans, et quand j'ai appris
à bien faire du wheeling
et tout, j'avais 11, 12 ans.
Ça fait longtemps que
je lève, quand même.
- Vous verrez, il est très fort.
Très, très fort.
- On va faire une petite démo.
Franchement, avec ça,
je te dis : tu fais tout.
T'es énervé, tu montes dessus,
tu décompresses directement.
Tu peux rouler pendant une heure comme tu peux rouler 10 heures sans t'arrêter
tellement c'est bien.
J'ai de l'amour pour ma bécane,
comme si c'était ma meuf.
J'ai fait plein de trucs
pour me payer des motos.
Vraiment, je faisais des pommes de
terre dans les champs, je les revendais.
Ouais, je te jure, c'est
vrai, je faisais des affaires
avec des vélos, des trottinettes,
des pommes de terre,
je vendais des betteraves,
si tu veux savoir aussi,
wallah, la tête de ma mère,
c'est vrai, gros,
avec ça, j'ai monté mon argent,
je vendais de la pâte à chicha,
je vendais de tout,
de tout, de tout, de tout.
C'est ça, Erwan. C'est ça, Erwan.
Bien plus bas, voilà.
Allez, Robin, c'est ça.
Allez, Erwan, c'est ça, continue,
c'est ça, les gars.
Eh, Enrique, c'est soit
tu cours, soit tu t'en vas,
tu te dépêches maintenant.
- Les Denaisiens,
faut aller les chercher,
c'est le truc ici,
faut aller les chercher.
Eh, j'avais pas souvenir
que pour bosser,
il fallait être assis par terre, les
gars. C'est quoi, c'est Club Med ici?
- Y a des gamins, à part traîner,
ils font rien de leur journée,
parce qu'ils sont
intéressés par rien.
Au coup de sifflet,
c'est ça le football, les gars,
on lâche rien, on donne tout.
Allez, suivant, suivant, suivant.
Ah là, si tu veux du brut au football
américain, tu vas être servie.
- Le sport, c'est une manière
de s'émanciper et de sortir un peu
de son quotidien.
Peu importe le milieu social,
moi, ce qui m'inquiète,
c'est quand un gamin,
il a pas de passion, il a pas de
hobbies, il a pas d'activités.
Eh, faut filmer ça, et ça, faut filmer.
Ici, regarde, c'est un peu
le terrain. Comme on disait,
moi, j'ai commencé là.
Oh, zeubi
wallah, elle est
monté en l'air, l'auto, gros.
- C'est bien, Denain ?
- Si, quand même.
- Tout ceux qui quittent Denain,
ils reviennent.
- Même si c'est shlag à mort,
mais Wallah, tout le monde revient.
tout le monde y revient, wallah.
Y a que des geuch à Denain.
Comme je t’ai dit, y a des spécimens,
t'as jamais vu
ça dans les autres villes.
Venez là ! Venez là !
Samedi,
c'est un match qu'on doit gagner
impérativement. C'est quoi la règle
quand on est absent?
Ouais, prévenir, juste dire "absent".
J'ai pas besoin de vos excuses
et j'ai surtout pas besoin
de vos excuses fausses.
Tu me dis "j'suis pas là, je bosse",
on voit tes stories Insta, t'es à Namur,
tu nous a pris pour
qui, des guignols ?
Non...
T'as cru... Mais réponds même pas !
T'as cru qu'on avait 70 ans,
qu'on n'était pas sur Instagram?
Arrêtez de vous
foutre de notre gueule,
t'es pas là, tu dis
"je suis pas là",
invente-nous pas des
couilles qui passent mieux,
genre je travaille, alors que
t'es avec ta gonzesse à Namur !
Arrêtez de nous vendre du flan.
c'est tout ce que je dis.
Au coin, c'est parti pour les diago.
Bah mon frère, c'était
un passionné de moto aussi,
il était vraiment fort en moto,
il gérait vraiment.
Lui, il m'avait un petit peu appris,
mais après, j'étais tout petit,
ça veut dire, lui, il me prenait devant et j'accélérais,
et, bah, y a eu plusieurs accidents et un jour, c'était l'accident de trop, en fait.
Il rentrait du terrain, fin
de journée, il rentrait du terrain,
et en rentrant du terrain, il a fait
un accident et, bah, il est décédé.
Bah ouais, je pense à mon frère
tous les jours, tout le temps.
Quand je roule en moto,
je pense à mon frère.
Quand je dors, quand... Tous les jours,
tous les jours où je me promène.
Bah, en vrai, non.
Mais mes parents, ils voulaient que j'arrête,
ils voulaient pas que
je continue la moto.
Quand ils nous voyaient
sur une moto,
bah, on n'avait plus le droit de sortir.
Amine, il a une histoire familiale
un peu compliquée.
Aujourd'hui, il vit avec sa tante
parce qu'il ne parle plus
du tout avec sa mère.
Bah ma mère, ouais,
je la vois tout le temps,
mais comme je vous ai dit,
je parle pas avec.
Après, ça reste ma
mère, c'est sûr, c'est pas...
je vais pas dire le contraire.
Mon père, chez lui, ils sont
un petit peu beaucoup.
Ça veut dire, moi,
je ne veux pas aller les déranger.
Après, y a des petits et tout,
c'est pour ça.
Après, mon père, il fait sa vie de son côté,
et moi, bah, je fais ma vie de mon côté.
Mais mon père, on est
toujours en contact,
tous les jours, on s'envoie
des messages,
tout le temps il prend des nouvelles de moi,
je prends des nouvelles de lui.
Après, comme je vous ai dit ici,
franchement, c'est vraiment
tous mes frères, chacun.
Si demain j'arrive à percer, et
que j'arrive à gagner quelque chose,
bah, je vais tout partager avec eux.
C'est ça, les gars !
Au football, vous avez votre taff
individuellement
qui doit participer
à la réussite collective.
Réfléchissez à ça, les gars, dans
la solidarité, dans le collectif.
Denain, c'est une ville ouvrière.
Enfin, c'était une ville ouvrière où
le taux de chômage avoisine les 35%
et c'est bien au dessus
de la moyenne nationale.
Moi, mon père me dit tout le temps :
à l'époque, ici, la plus grosse
ville, c'est Valenciennes.
Il dit :  "Moi, quand j'étais jeune,
personne ne parlait de Valenciennes.
La grosse ville, c'était Denain".
Pendant plus de deux heures, sidérurgistes
et forces de l'ordre vont s'affronter.
Je me suis fait mourir pour Usinor,
j'ai travaillé des journées
de 24 heures, faut le dire,
et maintenant, je me retrouve
à la rue, sans rien.
Il y a 40 ans, les industries
métallurgistes... donc, en l'occurrence,
Usinor a fermé, ce qui a mis
énormément de gens au chômage,
ça a eu un effet dévastateur.
Ça s'est fermé y a 40 ans
et je pense que la ville
s'en est pas remis complètement.
À chaque fois que je tombe
sur une photo de mes grands-pères,
je les vois, ils sont face à face
en train de parler
et y a la bouteille
de Ricard devant eux,
et tu te dis : bon, là, c'est sûr,
ils sont en train de parler
d'Usinor, en train de se faire
un jaune, c'est évident,
c'est... j'ai tellement vécu ça
toute mon enfance !
Allez, voilà, voilà, voilà.
Les cafés ont fermé,
les bars ont fermé.
Là, y a un cinéma
qui vient de rouvrir à Denain
depuis six mois maintenant.
Avant que le cinéma arrive là
y a six mois,
là, y a pas eu de cinéma à Denain
pendant je sais pas
combien d'années,
alors que c'est une
ville de 20 000 habitants.
- Les activités, bah... Pfff...
Déjà, y a la moto.
Ça, c'est là-dedans, ouais.
Et en vrai, je pourrais dire
que la moto, franchement,
après, y a les matchs FIFA,
y a des pokers clandestins...
Y a le terril
juste derrière le stade,
on sait très bien que les gamins,
avec leurs motos, ils vont dans le terril,
mais encore une fois,
c'est peut-être parce que
on les oriente pas
vers d'autres choses,
bah quand ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes,
ils font ce qu'ils savent faire.
Peut-être que si on les avaient
intéressés à d'autres choses,
ou même carrément des clubs de moto,
parce que ça existe aussi,
y a des gens qui font ça
de façon très structurée, et que,
ben, si vous voulez peut-être avoir de futurs talents,
venez à Denain,
vous allez peut-être en trouver.
Eh, j'ai fait la bavette,
je viens de faire la bavette.
Nan !!
Je suis la copine de son frère,
je suis tout le temps là.
Non, bah, j'ai grandi
dans ça, hein.
Vous savez, moi aussi j'ai roulé
en étant petite,
ma fille, elle roulait
en étant petite.
C'est de famille.
Bon, les gars, je vais pas
y aller par quatre chemins :
les pirates ne viendront pas.
Ils sont forfaits pour ce match.
J'aime pas gagner comme ça,
j'aime pas comment ça se passe,
et si le match, chez eux,
ils sont encore en lice,
eh bah on ira chez eux,
parce que s'ils ont la flemme
de venir jusqu'à Denain
de Normandie, bah nous,
on montrera qu'on a pas la flemme
et qu'on est prêts
à aller chez eux
pour leur mettre le cul par terre.
Nous, l'adaptation
qu'on a choisie aujourd'hui,
c'est de s'entraîner
malgré tout,
et on essaie de mettre
sa frustration dans...
dans l'entraînement
qui vient.
Eh ! Eh!
Les gars ! Les gars!
Expliquez-moi un truc :
pourquoi vous avez su être agressifs
et ultra dominants, là,
pendant un quart d'heure,
et là, vous êtes mous
comme des chèvres ?
Nous, on participe de facto au fait
que les jeunes soient moins isolés,
puisque nous, avec le club,
sur les cinq dernières années,
on envoyait chaque année
au moins un jeune au pôle
France de football américain,
et y en a deux aussi
qui sont partis
ou qui vont partir continuer l'aventure
football américain au Canada.
C'est des jeunes qui n'auraient
peut-être jamais voyagé si
y avait pas eu, à un moment donné,
le football américain.
Non, jamais, jamais, jamais.
Bah, mon rêve, pfff...
franchement, c'est d'aller rouler
avec les mecs aux États-Unis.
Ils sont vraiment forts hein,
je kifferais trop !
Bon, ça y est, elle commence
quand, la photo ?
Wallah, bsahtek ou pas,
le reportage ?
J'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu
et si vous voulez voir d'autres contenus, d'autres reportages,
hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
YouTube de Brut.
Et aussi laissez moi
des commentaires,
je les lirai et
je vous dis à bientôt.